my next guest has been hailed a hero
after saving a drowning student who had
slipped and fallen
into a river in china british diplomat
stephen
ellison jumped into the river after he
saw the 24 year old woman face down in
the water
and pulled her to the shore she was
unconscious when she was lifted out of
the water but has now made a full
recovery and has invited him to dinner
i'm pleased to say
that stephen ellison is joining us now
from china hello to you
very good morning good evening uh where
you are tell us
what happened it's great to see you good
morning morning kay yeah i'm i'm
definitely not a hero
um i was uh on my first trip out of
chongqing i actually just arrived in
chongqing about a month ago so i was
taking advantage of some really nice
weather we're having
uh and traveled uh down to this uh
beautiful village i'd heard called
zhongchan gujan of zhongchang old town
which was very beautiful um and just
enjoying the scenery by the river
and then a large group of students
arrived
and suddenly one of them very
unfortunately slipped in um
the river wasn't very big but she she
got into trouble
really quickly um and she you know
submerged into the water she seemed to
be under for a little while and then she
popped back up but face down just
floating
on the surface so um there was no
is no thinking i was just the first
person to able to get get my shoes i
took my shoes off so i could swim
properly and not to show my socks off
and
quickly got to her but when i reached
her and turned her over
she she wasn't breathing and she was
unconscious and i was
really was fearing the worst but then
friends were helping and threw in a life
boy and helped pull us both to the side
and then
as we got to the side actually she she
did start to breathe so i was i was
really
greatly relieved by that um she was
pulled out by
by the bystanders we got her out
and i could see that she was recovering
and then i
got myself out so uh it was a you know
it could have been a really
situation but so pleased it ended
happily
yeah when i saw the pictures of her
floating in the water like you i i
feared
at the worst but the reaction in china
has been
incredibly positive and it's not me
that's necessarily calling you a hero
although i think you are
um it's many of the chinese uh people
how does that make you feel
well quite humble i mean it was you know
it was a a tragic situation could have
been and i was just there but
look i mean that's as as anywhere uh
social media in china is uh very active
um
so the the video is very dramatic
um probably more dramatic than than the
actual event i i feel i feel like i feel
very very humble i'm you know with very
kind comments
um and um yeah so i'm just
just happy that it's all ended well and
i would also say
um that the villagers in jeongshan
guljen were so kind and so warm to me
um when i came out they were i was taken
straight into someone's house and given
a change of clothing and they washed and
dry my clothes
gave me some yunnan coffee and and
snacks and things
um so they're really really really
lovely people there
um and uh and then the young student was
able to to come in
she recovered a little bit later so we
we were able to
to meet each other in the afternoon um
and she's invited me for
for dinner next weekend which i'm i'll
be obviously honored to
uh to to meet her again
fantastic can we talk about the funky
socks
well yeah i i i
funky that's your your description i i i
i
they're certainly they've got some
comments um i
i what can i say
um that they i took my shoes off
honestly it was it was
my one goes back to sort of uh
school swimming lessons and things but
you're told always take your shoes off i
don't know what
makes much difference but i took my
shoes off exposed my socks which uh
clearly have uh caused uh some uh
attention uh but didn't take my phone
out of my pocket so my my phone stayed
in my pocket
i don't know what i was thinking there
but there we go
um what's what's the posting in china
how long are you there for
i'll be here for about three years i've
just arrived i mean i've been in china
i worked in the embassy before but i've
just arrived as a consul general in
chongqing in southwest china so i expect
to be here for three years
okay well that's certainly a way to make
a splash isn't it